[Music]
i'm here because of my mom
me too milo please don't ask me a
million questions oh come on now give me
some credit
hey does anyone call you danny uh not
really where are your parents from you
don't have to
and she's always been quirky i can't
help it i'm inquisitive
maybe a little neurotic it's loaded with
saturated fats i clog your arteries
oh bet nothing like this
what are you doing shh the neighbor
threw a rock at me
what yeah i was doing laundry i heard a
bang
aren't you scared that he's gonna murder
you in a sleep and bury you in this yard
oh my god well i wasn't until now she
thinks
our neighbor is stalking her climbing on
her roof every little noise she believes
is an attack
he's paying me to follow him how do i
convince my mom that it's all in her
head
that's gonna be hard she's off the edge
i'm not gonna sit back and do nothing do
you have any idea what i'm going through
did it even occur to you that i just got
fired from my job
[Music]
there's a mistake waiting to happen
[Music]
i don't need you in my life look what he
did to us my own daughter he turned
against me
ladies lovely
[Music]
you